the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski has said the latest Russian
attacks back up his case for more
weapons from the West at least 11 people
died in missile strikes yesterday and
Canada is the latest country to commit
tanks to Ukraine joining me now is a
retired AFI Vice Marshal Sean Bell
always great to speak to you and try and
find out what's going on I guess behind
all the headlines when it comes to
Ukraine and the headlines at the minute
are tanks why do you think Russia is so
concerned about these tanks the West has
been providing military sport for some
time now but this is a step change tanks
are the first time the West has moved
from a defensive support to offensive
support and that's a step change in
capability as you say overnight the
Russians or yesterday were 55 missiles
launched a huge wave of missile attacks
on the country uh 47 were shot down
allegedly but all 24 of the Shaheed the
Iranian provided drones they were all
shot down as well this is just Russian
frustration because they know how
critically important these tank these
tanks will be we've heard overnight that
the Canadians are now stepping in
they're going to provide four tanks it's
only a small number but they join a
coalition of 12 countries now all of
which will be focused on trying to get
these tanks into and similar Tanks off
to Ukraine won't just be the hardware
it'll also be focusing on spares support
ammunition and crucially training and
that training will be conducted in high
technology simulators very much like
flight simulators are they'll be in a
mock-up of a tank itself they'll be
looking out at what they look is that
feels like the real world and the
Russian threats they'll be fighting will
be driven by specialist simulator
operators to create the most realistic
immersive environment and having died
many times in a fast jet simulator to
make sure that you never have to do that
for real this will be some of the best
training available in the world for
these Ukrainian tank drivers yeah
fascinating stuff you have to look at
the pictures and all the tanks that we
were just seeing to realize the
technology behind it a potential Game
Changer as you say that's for the future
because obviously the training needs to
happen the tanks needs to arrive as
president zelensky told at K Burley
what's happening right now on the ground
then we look at the map we can get a
brief Canter of the update the vagaroop
are still very active around uh Bach
moot's here they're knocking on the door
but not really making much progress the
Russians interestingly have voted
they've had some success about the
volodar across him the Don bass but also
auricive across in the zaparita area the
problem is with this information is we
can't verify it from anywhere else and
of course it comes at the time when
President Putin is clamping down even
further on freedom of press what looks
most likely is these are foraging
attacks by the Russians probing the
Ukrainian defense because without a
doubt what Russia will be wanting to do
is Mount its major offensive before
these tanks get in Ukraine and Russia
will want to be gaining some momentum so
it could be really critical a few kind
of weeks and months ahead in that case
um I was interested when you're talking
about the difference between defensive
and offensive capabilities and president
zelinski has immediately I guess now
that he's got the tanks that he wanted
for moved on to talking about Jets do
you think that he could get them it was
interesting the shopping list wasn't it
asking for tanks for ages as soon as he
got those on his birthday immediately
asking for uh for for jets I think
what's interesting first of all it feels
like a shopping list but equipment
doesn't equal operational capability to
make to turn a bit of equipment into
capability you need training support by
way of example anti-tank weapons we're
providing if I was to give you one of
those within a day you'd probably be
able to fire it I'm not sure about that
but it's relatively simple maybe but if
you then go to tanks we're talking about
weeks or even months even for seasoned
operators as soon as you get to fast
Jets into this domain even if you've got
a seasoned campaigner like myself this
is your this is your my domain but it
would take in literally months or years
to convert these people and they just
don't have that sort of time Western our
power undoubtedly would prove a crucial
absolutely decisive effect on the
battlefield the challenge is you'd
probably have to put Western pilots in
there in order to exploit it and so far
the West is not actually prepared to put
combatants into this war in Ukraine but
it is worth noting President Biden when
we when the tanks were offered made
really clear to president sir Putin
these are not here to threaten Russian
soil they're simply to evict the same
logic actually applies for air power so
whilst I don't think there's any we're
going to see air power from the West
arrive in Ukraine anytime soon the
decision about the tanks makes that
decision just one step closer that's
really interesting uh always good to
talk thank you very much indeed